Yemen is an oil producer but at just a  hundred thirty three thousand barrels a  day it's only the 39th biggest oil  producer in the world in fact it  contributes less than 0.2 percent to  global output so why are events they are  roiling the oil market it's all about  location Yemen is located on bob almond  EV the fourth biggest shipping choke  point in the world by volume 3.8 million  barrels of oil and petrol passed through  it per day its closure would divert  tankers around the southern tip of  africa adding to cost and delivery time  more importantly yemen shares a border  with Saudi Arabia the world's biggest  exporter of crude oil after the  government collapsed Saudi Arabia  ordered airstrikes of rebel targets and  deployed troops thousands of barrels of  oil from Yemen aren't enough to disrupt  the market millions of barrels from  Saudi Arabia would be a different matter